et
l'une évoque avec poésie la douceur de
la campagne normande ses vallons et ses
maisons à colombages une autre plus
ludique rend hommage à la vache et
bocage mais qu'elle allie pomme fois
boîtes de camembert ou authentique sa
vie de domfront toutes sont inspirés du
terroir dont elle évoque la mémoire car
dans l'orne la créativité et l'esprit
d'entreprise passe aussi par l'art de la
table quand on s'est rendu compte qu'ils
avaient que lorgne élèves de la lance
qui s'occupait de faire un truc qui
changeait qu'à tirer beaucoup les gens
et c'est un truc assez sympa y réfléchir
être à lui ai dit qu'est ce qui te plaît
il attend club des gâteaux la mangera
bien même
à déguster avec les yeux uniquement ses
robes gourmande confectionné en une
quinzaine de jours rappellent les
saveurs de l'enfance pour illustrer la
richesse de sa région et ses traditions
le conseil général de l'orne a confié la
création de ces robes allégorique à une
styliste est un artiste peintre qui ont
tous deux travaillé pour une agence
spécialisée nôtres c'est notre métier de
créer des événements donc on cherche on
a toujours des produits qui sont
vraiment en adéquation avec la stratégie
de nos clients là c'était une opération
pour créer du trafic pour amener des
gens sur un tout petit espace et leur
faire découvrir l'ensemble des produits
et la région à l'issue du salon c'est
cette parure emblématique de l'orne où
seront exposées à l'hôtel du département
elle repasse un parmi nous c'est
formidable bravo nos vraies pommes les
poires elle sans doute quand les aboli
en camp s'il vous plaît pour ses tenues
absolument formidable